a depressing and now familiar possum
elderly with underlying health
conditions the sixth and latest UK
coronavirus death this time coming here
in Watford the rising numbers have today
again prompted questions about Britain's
capacity to cope well of course we have
to plan for a reasonable worst-case
scenario but we're working incredibly
hard to avoid that scenario but
according to Jonathan Ashworth mr.
Hancock's opposite number the
government's assurances lack detail he
is asked repeatedly for exact critical
care capacity figures I think we need
absolute clarity from the government on
the number of intensive care beds that
are available the number of oxygen
ventilators that are available and the
number of these very high-end specialist
ECMO beds that are available ECMO beds
are used only for the most critically
ill patients after the 2009 swine flu
epidemic the government was recommended
to double its capacity NHS England has
told Sky News it now has over 30 of
these beds significantly more than the
original five to understand what might
happen here the government is following
developments in Europe where cases
continued to search the number of cases
in Italy rocketed from the hundreds to
the thousands in just a few weeks and
the same thing is expected to happen
here their health care system was
completely overwhelmed but it's their
critical care capacity greater than ours
NHS England has just over four thousand
adult critical care beds that's around
seven beds for every 100,000 people
that's way behind Germany and France and
even Italy which has almost double but
around 75 percent of England's critical
care beds are currently full London has
the highest occupancy in England at 78
percent with the lowest in the eastern
region at 68 percent while the UK's
other nations are in a worse position
ninety-five percent of critical care
beds in Northern Ireland and Wales are
full and 84 percent in Scotland the
government says the NHS is prepared and
ready to cope with the worst case
Naru but everyone is hoping that it
never has to ashes joshi skeins